it may be their freedom day
[Music]
but in wales like anywhere else it's
been a long pandemic
as cardiff city take on barnsley a
minutes silence a moment to remember
fans who died during the covet crisis
for many it's the first time back to see
live football
entry to the ground is now via
electronic barcode
scanned at the gates on arrival went
straight through the turnstiles it
beeped
easy very easy for both of us and that
was it we're in
yeah and ellis how excited are you to be
back at a football game
extremely excited i haven't been here
for ages it feels just like
a normal football match except it's not
really the stadium's only at half
capacity when it comes to opening up
slowly cautiously seems to be the
approach here
we've continued to be cautious you'll
have heard me and
other ministers regularly say that about
our approach
but there is real confidence the vaccine
is making a significant difference
in the second wave that we went through
in the winter just gone
about ten percent of people with
infections ended up in hospital
now it's a little under two percent
there's plenty to celebrate here
[Applause]
as limits on people gathering indoors
are lifted wales is now at alert level
zero nick tells me this giant
hospitality venue
opened just before the first lockdown
and it's a relief to be fully back up
and running
that's the word relaxed they are i think
coming in not
knowing they don't have to keep on at
people to say can you please
do this can you please do that it is a
relief i think the customer's going to
feel a bit more relaxed coming today and
hopefully it should be a good day
and do they feel more relaxed it is
wonderful
just to be out amongst people boasters
are still really nervous
still keeping our distance but it feels
so good to be back i'd rather people
wear a mask and socially distance
personally but yeah i can't really
control that i guess
like england a few weeks ago wales is
now experimenting with freedom
with scotland and northern ireland
expected to follow suit in the next few
weeks
the nations can now look forward to a
tentative return
towards normal life harriet hadfield sky
news
cardiff